قبل شويه سمعت شاب قال بونو بطل اسمه بونو
صار له اسمه بوينو يعني كبير يعني منيح
هذه الاشياء بدات بدات تظهر ترينز
بعد هذه المباراه اتفضل اوكي اماك اخوك
سليم عبد الوهاب من المغرب من مدينه افران
مدينه اسود الاطلس اوكي لان عندنا قلب
المدينه في اسد حجري منحوت هو رمز لاسود
الاطلس طب شو رايك باسود الاطلس اللي هو
الاسود
حق المغرب يحقق نتيجه
كل العالم ورانا بعد ما شاء الله الحمد
لله هذا انجاز قوي فانا قلت بعد سوف نعيد
كره طارق بن زياد ودخول الاندلس فاحنا
دخلنا الى مدريد وان شاء الله بننتظر
البرتغال بعد نعم و نعيد كره سيباستيان
شكرا شكرا شكرا السلام عليكم
حماس كبير وتقى الناس اللي كانوا
بجانبي كانت عندهم ثقه ان شاء الله النخبه
الوطنيه المغربيه تقوم بالواجب وتتاهل ان
شاء الله
بفضل الله وجهودات اللعيبه
والاطار
المغربي
وكل الناس اللي ساهموا في الانجاز ان شاء
الله
هناك مباريات قادمه هل ههه
نعم هلا راح تغير رايك ترجع على المغرب
ورح تبقى هنا
قررت انني اجي لهون علشان الدور 16 خديت
ااا اسبوع
النهائي اه اوكي كان عندك شعور انه راح
يفوز المغرب وشعورك صح المغرب شكرا لكم